happy New Year Sid trekers and welcome
to your look at what's coming up in 2024
welcome to Sid Treck your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel so I've picked some of the
movies that we have definitely going to
be getting in the first part of 2024 and
some of the TV series too also we're
going to have a little bit of look at
what we think is rumored that's going to
be going into production this year even
though we might not quite get it on our
screens just yet first of all let's look
at the movies so we're going to be
getting June part two now I have to say
that this has been delayed repeatedly
mainly because of the strikes and other
issues on set but this is something that
I think is going to be worth waiting for
finally we're going to be getting to see
the second part of this epic I loved the
first part I thought Jason Mamoa in
particular was brilliant the lad that
played Wonka was probably my favorite
movie last year and he's going to be
returning as well so June part two is
the first thing I'm going to say to you
to look forward to in 2024 we're also
getting a new alien movie Alien Romulus
this movie really is going to be a part
of a much bigger alien franchise because
we're getting the TV series as well
Disney are not messing around with this
they 100% are trying to take advantage
of this franchise so alien Romulus is
going to be the first part of that but
which Disney are we actually going to be
getting with this are we going to be
getting the Disney that can't seem to
make a movie to save its life or are we
going to be getting the traditional
Juggernaut production company we were at
one point used to let's hope that Disney
have learned its lessons from last few
years and have actually figured out how
to make this movie half decent because
the alien xenomorph creature is one of
those iconic bad guys really if you
can't make a decent alien movie you
shouldn't be in the movie business
Mickey 17 is a movie star in Robert
Patterson he is Batman but he's also
Mickey and Mickey and Mickey and Mickey
this movie is about a long space journey
basically and every time Mickey is the
the guy that is aboard the ship and is
the sort of like the Explorer dies um a
new version of himage regenerated and
each version of Mickey only has some of
the memories of the previous so this is
going to be a film based around the 17th
incarnation of this deep space astronaut
I actually think that the premise of
this is quite interesting and
particularly for a high concept sci-fi
movie I'm quite looking forward to
seeing what they do with this the last
movie I'm going to say that to you guys
that I'm really really looking forward
to but I have some reservations about is
the new Ghostbusters film when
Ghostbusters afterlife was released I
was amazed by how well they did it
really was a worthy sequel to The
Originals and I AB absolutely loved it I
was able to exclusively tell you first
when um it was green lit for the sequel
but I do have my concerns this movie is
getting to our theaters really really
quickly and how many times before have
we seen when particularly a movies had a
little bit of a surprise hit which I
think to be fair Ghostbusters was nobody
was really sure how well it was going to
do and they were really pleased with
just how well it did do that they may
have decided to rush the sequel and get
it out you know strike while the iron is
hot how many times have we seen
Hollywood do that before and how many
times has absolutely ruined a franchise
I've always believed that this actually
was kind of part of the plan and that
this movie was already in mind when they
were creating the first movie so when
afterlife was being written they had
this in mind there were several little
nods to it actually in afterlife and I
actually am hopeful we're going to get
something that is well planned and well
thought through not something rushed TV
series that we can look forward to in
the next couple of months now there are
some really really exciting things
coming in
2024 Fallout is okay I did play this
game years ago I've actually just
remembered literally this morning when I
was you know looking at all the
different forite things that I remember
that years ago I actually did play the
first version of this I've forgotten all
about it it was a game that yeah I
thought was all right it's a
post-apocalyptic storyline if you don't
know and go and check out some of the
early clips from Amazon it does look
like this could be very very interesting
it is made by the same guys that um were
heavily to do with the boys I do expect
to see something quite violent but the
game was so that would be in keeping
with the tradition of that and I just
think this is a series that if done well
could be really good there's loads of
storylines from the games that they get
to play with and obviously to inspire
the writers to come up with something a
bit different as well I actually think
this is a massive universe and if they
do it right oh it could be good a series
I'm a little bit more hesitant to
suggest will be great is the three body
problem Sam tar from Game of Thrones is
coming back can't remember his real name
but actually he's an actor I quite like
he's in this the three body problem
though is very high con C I actually
read this when I was a kid it's
obviously based on um a novel back in
the day and I have to tell you it's a
mind Bender you really do have to
concentrate and if this version is true
to the novels which to be honest if it's
not there's going to be uproar then it
is going to be something you will need
to concentrate when
watching but isn't that a good thing
doesn't sci-fi when done well make you
think about it do doesn't sci-fi when
it's done well make you maybe change the
way you think about things this story is
that type of thing it is it's it's a
layered project there's lots going on
there's lots of Concepts there is really
more going on than just what you see on
the surface if you want to see a Sci-Fi
show that in theory at least should get
you thinking this is it avatar the Last
air bender is one of the most expensive
TV shows ever made it's cost on average
15 to 16 million an episode in fact
Netflix have really thrown money at this
now we saw the animated cartoon of the
last air bender Harris our young
American genuinely says this is one of
his favorite projects ever it's a TV
show that he adored and to be honest I
even watched the animated show when I
was a little bit younger and I loved it
too the movie that was produced by
midnight something I can't say his name
um I'm not going to try um by midnight
was a bit of a disappointment it didn't
quite work and it didn't meet
expectations so can this series do that
well we've seen a lot of clips from it
it does look like it's at very least
going to be beautifully shot and it will
be a feast for the eyes but will there
be the story well there's lots of story
there for them to explore let's just
hope they do it properly I actually am a
little bit in two minds about this I'm
hopeful but hesitant now Marvel has been
a little bit disappointing the last
couple of years I think it's fair to say
on TV and movie and I honestly hand on
heart think that secret invasion was one
of the worst things I've ever forced
myself to watch I would rather put my
Gentleman sausage in a vice and twist
the thing until there's a Poppin noise
then watch it again I really really
hated it so why am I suggesting that
Echo will be any different
well from lots of the clips that we've
seen it does look like eeko that is
really going to follow on from the um
Hawkeye series we saw um two years ago
now um with the um deaf character and
we're also going to see the Kingpin
greatest character in Marvel it does
feel like though that this series is
going to follow on more like the
original Daredevil series that we saw on
Netflix that sort of vibe and um style
and let's be honest the best Marvel
stuff that we've had in recent history
on television at least has been the
stuff they did with Netflix so that's
what we want to see this is going to be
action-packed it's going to be violent
there is some going to be some
incredible acting in it let's be honest
and I really think that this could be
Marvel getting back on track now Loki
season two was good but this has the
possibility of being properly brilliant
and actually I'm being told that the
main reason why they've decided to scrap
what they started with the actual new
Daredevil reborn series and start again
which is something they announced during
the strikes is mainly because of echo
initially they were going to have
elements of sort of shehulk in this new
Daredevil series and there was going to
be an element to follow on from that
that was decided to be scrapped and
instead it will have far more of the
feel of echo now I think we can all
agree that that sounds like a much
better idea but how about stuff that
hasn't actually gone into produ yet but
we think will this year well I think
there's two major projects that I think
we can look forward to Warhammer 40K
does look like it's now going into
proper development Henry cavil went a
little bit quiet on the project but now
and recent weeks has done some very
promising updates it does seem that he
is going to get his dream and he's going
to be able to get to make this series
right now they're looking at partners
and they're looking at how basically
this is going to happen the development
process for series like this will be
lengthy I actually suspect it'll take up
most of the year at least for example
let's look at the other project God of
War we've known about that for 18 months
and still it hasn't gone into production
I'm being told it's going to go into
production very shortly and actually
should start filming in the late
spring so Warhammer 40K we can expect
not to see on our screens probably until
2020 h maybe even six but at very least
it won't be until
2025 but I'm being told that both of
these projects will be going into some
level of production this year hey God of
War we might even get to see by the end
of this year who knows the last project
I want to talk about is one that I have
a little bit of trepidation about Halo
season 2 now obviously this isn't a new
series this is a returning Series so it
doesn't really fit with this video but I
wanted to talk about it because I have a
sour who's actually seen some early cuts
of it and he's telling me look if you
enjoyed Halo season 1 you're going to
love Halo season 2 but if you didn't
like Halo season 1 still give season 2 a
chance because it's like a new show The
Source who's seen bits of it has
basically said look they've obviously
listened to the um complaints about the
first season and they've done something
that feels way more like the Halo games
this is going to be far more visually
spectacular for one there's going to be
far more aggressive violence think about
the first couple of minutes of the first
season and imagine that spread
throughout the entire season that's the
kind of thing he's talking about so I'm
hopeful that Halo season 2 will be a
second chance for this series because I
have to say the first season got a
little boring I actually think I stopped
watching it I did go back to it but I
think I stopped watching it halfway
through so let's hope that season two
though can fulfill the promise because
let's be honest a bit like
Fallout Halo has a massive wealth of
Cannon it has an entire universe to
explore it really should be quite easy
to make a show that is exciting let's
hope the Paramount have managed it this
time and it'll be on our screens in the
next few months so those are the things
that I'm looking forward to most in the
first part of 2024 but what are you
looking forward to get over into the
comments I'd love to know what series
you think will be good and what series
you think are going to miss the target
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you're thinking if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you'll never miss any
of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com citrek where most of our new
videos Premiere first and you get to see
them without the adverts also go to
c.o. which is our dedicated website and
we do articles based on a lot of our
videos so if you want to find out what's
actually going on go and check out the
website as always please stay safe happy
New Year and I'll see you
[Music]
soon